Hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Christian Bayer, ich bin als Astensarzt,
ich bin auf der Station tätig, ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Asten annehmen.
Ich habe im Augenblick kein Bild, ah, jetzt sind Sie wieder da, ich hatte zwischendurch
kein Bild von Ihnen. Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir, das ist nett, wenn Sie mir helfen wollen, ja.
Ok, kurz zum Ablauf, ich werde Ihnen zuerst
manche Fragen zu Ihren Daten stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Maria Zimaman.
Maria Zimaman.
Können Sie Ihre Vorname bestabieren?
Ja, Maria M-A-R-I-A.
Ok, Zimaman mit W-M.
W-M und am Ende W-M, ja.
In der Mitte W-M und am Ende W-M.
Gut, wie alt sind Sie, Frau Maria Zimaman?
Ja, ich bin bald 66.
66.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 2. Mai 56.
56.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin ein 70 und wie ich 78 kg.
78?
Ok, schon, Frau Maria Zimaman.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe solche heftigen Schmerzen auf der linken Seite im Unterbauch.
Und ja, das wird irgendwie gar nicht besser.
Und nach dem Essen ist es besonders unangenehm,
gerade wenn ich etwas Fettiges gegessen habe.
Ich habe kürzlich Bratkartoffeln gegessen.
Oh, danach ging es mir so schlecht.
Darf ich Sie unterbrechen? Was haben Sie gegessen?
Ich habe Bratkartoffeln gegessen.
Bratkartoffeln?
Wann?
Da kommt ziemlich viel Fett rein.
Da kommt ziemlich viel Fett rein und das ist mir gar nicht gut bekommen.
Wann genau?
Seit wann haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Ja, das ist jetzt so zwei Wochen, dass das immer schlimmer wird.
Ich hatte aber schon mal so vor vier Wochen, fünf Wochen,
habe ich das schon mal so ein bisschen gehabt und dann ist es wieder weggegangen.
Da habe ich gedacht, ach, ist schon nicht so schlimm.
Aber jetzt ist es wiedergekommen und jetzt wird es eigentlich immer schlechter.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind sie eher dunkel oder krampfartig?
Ich kann das eigentlich nicht gut beschreiben.
Vielleicht, ja, vielleicht sind die dunkel.
Das könnte es vielleicht sein.
Aber ja, ich habe auch oft mal so Blähungen.
Dann hat man so diese typischen Stechen den Schmerzen eigentlich,
bis das dann wieder weg ist.
Und meine Verdauung ist sowieso auch ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ich habe immer mal wieder Durchfall und dann bin ich wieder verstopft
und dann habe ich wieder Durchfall.
Das ist ich kann mich da nie so richtig drauf verlassen.
Ja.
OK.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzschale von ein bis zehn,
wobei ein sehr leichten, sehr starken Schmerzen.
Ach ja, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Jetzt im Augenblick geht es mir erträglich, sage ich mal.
Aber vorhin waren die Schmerzen wirklich doll.
Das schwangt, ja?
Also mal sind die sicherlich erträglich so bei vier oder fünf oder so.
Und manchmal sind die eben auch mehr.
Dann würde ich vielleicht sagen sieben.
Ja.
OK. Verstehe.
Sind Ihnen übel?
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ist mir übel.
Nee, also richtig übel ist mir nicht.
Ich habe nur eigentlich keinen Appetit.
Das fällt mir auf.
Es schmeckt mir so gar nicht zurzeit.
Ja.
Haben Sie Erbrechen?
Nee, übergeben muss ich mir gehen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Was ich wohl habe.
Ja, so wenn ich, wenn ich, was wir gegessen haben,
also wenn ich gerade auch ein bisschen fettige Sachen gegessen habe,
dass ich dann so ein bisschen so brennen habe.
OK, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie spüren,
die Schmerzen in linken Unterbauch.
Früher war auch so.
Am Anfang war auch in linken Unterbauch.
Ja, ich meine, da hat das von Anfang an war das da.
Ja.
OK, aber mit der Zeit
sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Sie haben sich mit der Zeit verschlechtert.
OK.
Im, im Ihren Stuhl haben Sie ungewöhnliches etwas bemerkt.
Können Sie dich die Ihre Stuhl beschreiben?
Naja, das ist halt mal so und mal so,
manchmal habe ich Durchfall,
dann ist das alles ganz wässrig
und oftmals auch einfach ein bisschen weich
und nicht so gut verdaut.
Dann kann ich erkennen, was ich gegessen habe.
Und ein anderes Mal habe ich Verstopfung,
dass ich denke, oh, jetzt wird es aber Zeit,
dass ich irgendwann mal auf die Toilette kann.
Ja, wenn Sie Durchfall haben,
wie ist die Farbe Ihr Stuhl und wie ist die Konsistenz?
Oder?
Ja, das ist weich, weich oder manchmal auch flüssig,
je nachdem, das kommt drauf an.
Und die Farbe ist halt immer so kackbraun, wie das so ist.
Ja, braun.
OK, ja, keine besondere Farbe,
nicht schwarz und nicht hell und ja, es ist braun.
Ja.
OK, Sie haben schon gesagt mit
fetterreichen Essen, die beschwerden.
Ja, das bekommt wir gar nicht.
Haben Sie eine andere Ausglöse bemerkt?
Nee, sonst ist mir eigentlich nichts aufgefallen.
Haben Sie sonst weitere Beschwerden?
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Ich meine, ich habe ja noch eine Menge
Vorerkrankungen, die machen mir natürlich auch immer noch so ein bisschen Zipperlein.
Aber sonst, ich glaube,
jetzt, was da neu dazugekommen ist, war da nichts.
Nee, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zurückgenommen?
Oh, nee, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, ich wiege immer gleich.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber.
Ja, ich habe zwar nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich tatsächlich so ein bisschen
bisschen wärmer als sonst.
Ja, aber Sie haben nicht gemessen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nee.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachtweiß?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also Nacht, dass ich schwitze.
Nee, nee, das war früher in den Wechseljahren, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber Nacht muss ich wohl
hin und wieder mal auf die Toilette gehen.
In der Nacht?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie viel mal gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
In der Nacht?
Ja, nicht jede Nacht, aber oftmals einmal in der Nacht oder so.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, eigentlich beim Einschlafen habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten und durchschlafen
eben, ja, insofern, dass ich eben zwischendurch auf die Toilette muss.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen
zu Ihren Feuerkrankungen stellen, um ein Unfall so zu erhalten.
Gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Sie haben schon gesetzt, sechs Jahrzehnte leiden Sie unter.
Richtig.
Ja, also da kann ich ja eine ganze Liste aufführen.
Also einmal habe ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, das habe ich schon lange,
schon seit 15 Jahren.
Dann hat man
dann hat man mal vor ein, zwei Jahren hat man festgestellt,
dass ich Herzrhythmusjörungen habe.
Ja, dann hat der Arzt auch festgestellt,
dass meine Blutfettwerte zu hoch sind.
Na ja, gut.
Okay.
Und dann
seit wann
bitte
feststellte Blutfettwerte
hochblutfettwerte.
Ich kann Sie jetzt gerade nicht verstehen, wir haben eine Störung in der Leitung.
Fragen Sie noch mal bitte.
Ich möchte fragen, seit wann leiden Sie unter
Fettwerte erhöht?
Ah, dass die Fettwerte erhöht.
Oh, das ist schon zehn Jahre, dass der Arzt das festgestellt hat.
Okay.
Ja, dann habe ich immer mal wieder Erkrankungen.
Ja, ich habe immer mal wieder Blasenentzündungen
und seit einiger Zeit machten wir auch meine linke Hüfte zu schaffen.
Und da habe ich wohl Arthrose in der Hüfte.
Aber da ist noch keine Operation erfolgt.
Im Augenblick kumpelt ich noch so rum.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, die Gallenblase ist rausgekommen vor
ist auch schon wieder eine Weile her 20 Jahren.
Und dann hatte ich auch
die Gebärmutteroperation.
Entschuldigung, ich unterbreche Sie.
Wann war Gallenblase in fernem Kooperation?
Das ist 20 Jahre her.
Okay.
Und die Gebärmutter ist vor zwölf Jahren entfernt worden.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein?
Ja, dann nehme ich
ein Besserblocker.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass das ein Besserblocker ist,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Dann nehme ich
Atovastatin, 20 Milligramm.
Das nehme ich am Abend.
Und wenn mir die Knochen zu weh tun,
dann nehme ich mal Volterin.
Volterin, Tablette.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Muss ich gerade überlegen, habe ich Allergien?
Das ist keine richtige Allergie.
Ich kann Milchprodukte nicht gut vertragen.
Okay.
Wie äußert sich diese Intolerasur?
Ja, ich kriege dann halt
vermehrt Blähungen und Bauchschmerzen.
Und deswegen lasse ich das von vornherein weg.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Nie, vorher auch nie.
Nee, noch nie geraucht.
Gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, nicht regelmäßig, würde ich sagen.
Ich trinke nun wieder mein Glas Wein.
Wie oft ungefähr?
Ach, vielleicht zwei, drei Mal in der Woche oder so.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich, das würde eine mäßige Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder haben Sie ein Drogen ausprobiert?
Nein, nein, nein.
Mit so etwas habe ich nie etwas zu tun gehabt.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ach, ja, meine Mutter, die hat genauso wie ich,
der war immer,
sorry, ich habe die Patienten durcheinander gemacht.
Ja, das ist der Hacken.
Meine Mutter hat tatsächlich jetzt im Alter ein Diabetes bekommen.
Und mein Vater ist schon lange gestorben, der hat ja einen Lungenkrebs.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wobei, das sind natürlich keine Kinder mehr,
die sind inzwischen erwachsen und die wohnen auch nicht mehr zu Hause bei uns.
Ja, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja, ja.
Gut, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Mit meinem Mann.
Richtig?
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen, ja.
Ich bin hier eine Frau.
Schillig.
Ja, Schillig, Frau Sinema.
Alles gut, ja.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ja, ich bin sehr kurz im Rente, ein Glück.
Ich habe in einem Autohaus gearbeitet, im Büro, ne?
Was war Ihre Aufgabe in Arbeit?
Ja, ich habe da halt im Büro gearbeitet,
Abrechnung gemacht und Korrespondenz erledigt.
Büroarbeit, ja.
Bitte?
Ja, ich verstehe, okay.
Ich habe notiert.
Frau Sinema, ich habe eine Frage.
Gibt es eine, oder gibt es eine
haben Sie etwas versucht, um die Schmerzen zu linden?
Oder haben Sie etwas angenommen gegen die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe mal versucht, ein Paracetamol zu nehmen.
Und das habe ich zweimal hintereinander gemacht,
aber dann irgendwie hat das nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Sinema, ich habe meine ganze Frage geschrieben.
Haben Sie an mich Fragen oder fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Ja, ich habe natürlich nur die Frage an Sie.
Was kann das denn sein?
Was steckt denn dahinter?
Warum habe ich diese Schmerzen?
Ja, wir als Erste haben immer drei Schritte,
um die richtige Diagnose stellen zu können.
Wir haben nur das Anasegespräch verändert.
Wir brauchen noch weitere Schritte.
Ich werde sie erst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich ihnen abnehmen, gegebenenfalls manche
Bildgebende untersuchen gehen, wie zum Beispiel Ultrasonographie
durchveranlassen.
Dann werde ich rechtzeitig über die weitere Schritte informieren.
Okay, gut.
Wenn Sie keine Fragen mehr haben, ich würde Sie gerne
körperlich untersuchen.
Okay, ja.
Ich warte dann im Wartezimmer, ne?
Ja, bitte.
Nehmen Sie einen Platz im Wartezimmer.
Ja, sehr gut.
Hat noch jemand ergänzende Fragen?
Eine Frage.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie siebisch belastet?
Ich meine, haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit, in der Familie?
Ich bin ja jetzt rennen eigentlich, ich habe keinen Stress,
sondern weil ich Arbeit bin.
Also gut.
Und vielleicht, ich habe nichts gehört.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in den Wienbruch hinaus?
Ich weiß jetzt tatsächlich nicht, ob der Doktor
das gefragt hat, aber sie strahlen nicht aus.
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie Gesprächsbereit sind, ne?
Okay, nur brauche ich einen Minuten.
Ja, alles gut.
Okay.
Danke.
Darf ich anfangen?
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Obersten.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Patientin.
Ich möchte Sie erzählen.
Ja, erzählen Sie, was ist mit ihr?
Okay.
Ich möchte heute Ihnen eine 66-jährige Patientin,
Marie Simmermann berichten, vorstellen.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns seit 4-5 Wochen bestehende
heftiger, dumfer, linken Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen, seit 2 Wochen verschlechtert sich.
Die Schmerzen würden nach dem fettreichem Essen ausgelöst.
Auslösen.
Würden durch fettreiches Essen ausgelöst?
Ja, noch einmal den Satz korrekt.
Die Schmerzen werden durch fettreiches Essen ausgelöst.
Die Schmerzen hätten nach dem fettreichem Essen ausgelöst.
Ne, sie hätten nach fettreichem Essen begonnen,
oder sie werden durch fettreiches Essen ausgelöst.
Oder man sagt, fettreiches Essen löst die Schmerzen aus.
Das sind 3 Varianten, aber was anderes dazwischen geht nicht.
Die Schmerzen würden ausgelöst.
Durch fettreiches Essen ausgelöst.
Aus dem Klack hat die Patientin über Meteorismus Pyrosis.
Die Patientin bewertete die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala mit 5 von 10.
Laut der Patientin kommt manchmal Obst-Passion und manchmal Diarrh.
Wie lange hat sie dies schon?
Seit 2 Wochen.
Leider die Patientin unter Durchfall- und Verstopfung-Problem.
Der Patientin sei keine Auffälligkeiten in der Stuhl bemerkt.
Seien aufgefallen oder hätte bemerkt?
Die Patientin hat Paracetamol gegen die Beschwerden eingenommen,
aber die Einnahme von Medikamenten hat keine Linderung geschafft.
Er braucht.
Die Patientin fühle sich fieberig, aber sie habe nicht Fieber gemessen.
Die Patientin hat unter Nocturne Durchschlafungsstörungen.
Außer diese Auffälligkeiten haben die Patientin keine vegetativen Störungen.
An Vorerkrankungen seien bei der Patientin seit 15 Jahren Artelehypertonie,
seit 2 Jahren Arithmie, seit 5 Jahren Hypalipidemia und Blödenentschindungen.
Was für eine Entschindung?
Sistitis und Kokosarthrose.
Die Patientin hat sich vor 20 Jahren Kohlesterektomie und vor 12 Jahren Hysterektomie untersorgelt.
Die Patientin nimmt regelmäßig ein Beta-Blocko, der die Bekannte von Medikamenten nicht bekannte.
Diese Medikamente nehme ich 2 Mal pro Tag, sie hat 20 Milligramm Atorvastatin, einmal abends und bei der folgenden Tablette ein.
Die Patientin hat Lachosimpulens, die sich durch Blähungen und Bauchschmerzen äußeren.
Die Patientin sei nicht raucherin, trinke 1-2-3 Mal pro Woche.
Die Drogenkonsum wurde verneid.
Die Familien an einem Nestig, die Abites Melitostypsi bei der Mutter und der Vater sei wegen Lungen oder Anlungenkrebs gestorben.
Ja, Fachbegriff?
Das ist ein sehr guter Schritt.
Sehr gut!
Die Patientin wurde verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder, die gesund sind.
Sie leben mit ihrem Mann.
Sie sei berühmt hätte, Büroarbeiterin.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf die Vertikulitis aus.
Differenzial Diagnostik kommen, Darmkrebs oder Kolonkarcinom, vielleicht kolonisch-entsündliche Darmerkrankung.
Ja, sehr gut.
Qualitäts-Üsterosa oder Crohn, oder was zur Zeit oft im Gespräch ist bei vielen Leuten.
Reizdarmsyndrom, das ist irgendwie so, dass es mit allen Leuten eingeredet wird, sie hätten das glaube ich.
Ja, gut. Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich die Patienten folgenden Maßnahmen durchführen.
Als erstes würde ich sie körperlich untersuchen bei der Inspektion,
ob es eine Narbel, Icterus oder Echymosis gibt.
Bei der Palpation achte ich darauf, ob es Abwärtsspannung, Loslasschmerzen gibt,
bei der Ausgiltation überprüfe ich, ob es ein oder wie Darmgeräusch ist.
Bei der Palpation achte ich darauf, ob es Gedenfte oder Timpanische klop-schal gibt.
Was machen Sie operativ und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labo-Untersuchung könnte manche wichtigen Hinweisen liefern.
Im Labo sollten Blutbild-Entsündungparameter wie zum Beispiel BCG, CRP, Lykosythen untersucht werden.
Um die Diagnose so sicher zu werden, sollten Bauchultrashall gegebenenfalls
eine Spiegelung oder Kolonoskopie eingeleitet werden.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Sonografie?
Bei der Sonografie kann eine Entsündung entstehen, kann Freifüßigkeit feststellen.
Wenn es eine geneukologische Probleme gibt, können wir auch diese Krankheiten ausschließen.
Die Patienten haben Historektomie, aber die können vielleicht Verwachsungen entstehen.
Wenn sich das bestätigt, dass es eine Divertikulitis gibt, dann ist es eine Darumwand.
Was macht man?
Wenn sich das bestätigt, dann machen Sie eine Behandlung?
Wenn eine Entsündung entsteht, dann sollten wir Antibiotikum, Analgetikum, Antipredikum einsetzen.
Aus der Komplikation empfehlen wir Allgemeinmaßnahmen wie ausgewogene Ernährung und Ballerstoff reichenden Ernährung.
Kriegt die Patienten im Augenblick auch etwas zu essen?
Sie haben eine Entsündung, die eine Divertikulitis hat.
Kriegt die etwas zu essen?
Wenn eine Komplikation entsteht, dann können wir die Erkutel bestätigen, dann werden wir die Ärzte erst mal erlaufen lassen.
Wenn unsere Reichende Medikamenteusetherapie interventionelle Behandlungen haben,
dann können wir die Ärzte erst mal erlangen.
Wenn unsere Reichende Medikamenteusetherapie interventionelle Behandlungen haben, dann können wir die Erkutel behandeln.
Was wäre das?
Objektum oder Antipredikum?
Von mir aus ist das alles.
Dann setzen Sie mal die Untersuchung bei der Patientin fort und halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, wie es ihr geht und was Sie rausgefunden haben.
Und ob sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt hat.
Gut.
Hat noch jemand Frage oder Hinweise?
Emre, hast du noch irgendwelche Fragen oder Tipps?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich hatte ein Problem, weil unsere Verbindung nicht super gut war.
Das Bild hat immer wieder gestockt und manchmal konnte ich sie ein bisschen schwer verstehen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie tatsächlich diese Standardformulierung, da muss man aufpassen, dass man da nicht falsche Grammatik nimmt.
Die einfach nochmal überprüfen auf korrekte Grammatik.
Das ist natürlich blöd, wenn man sich so etwas angewöhnt, dass man das immer in der gleichen Weise sagt, es ist immer falsch.
Zum Beispiel, ob das aktiv oder passiv ist, ist relativ wichtig.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das Beispiel war.
Ich mache immer solche Fehler.
Ich beginne mit aktiv und am Ende passiv.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und dann passt es halt nicht zusammen.
Da muss man einfach ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man die Formulierung nochmal sauber macht.
Ich kann Ihnen anbieten, dass Sie Ihren schriftlichen Bericht mir eine E-Mail schicken, dass ich den einmal durchgucke und schreiben Sie ihn so, wie Sie ihn sonst auch schreiben würden.
Jetzt also noch nicht super kontrolliert, sondern so, wie Sie ihn sonst auch schreiben würden.
Und dann könnte ich Ihnen einfach sagen, das ist ein klassischer Fehler, den Sie da und da machen.
Ich kann es nur anbieten, wenn Sie mögen, machen Sie das.
Emre hat die E-Mail-Adresse und kann die ihn schicken.
Danke.
Gut.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen schwer gehabt mit der Verbindung.
Sie sprechen noch ein bisschen stocken.
Das geht nicht so ganz flüssig.
Ja, aber man kann sie tatsächlich so von der Aussprache her sehr, sehr gut verstehen.
Und natürlich habe ich auch immer verstanden, was Sie meinen.
Ja, der Arztkollege wird Sie auch verstehen, was Sie ihm sagen wollen.
Aber trotzdem in der Fachsprachprüfung geht es natürlich auch um richtige Frage.
Und insofern müssen wir da einfach nochmal ein bisschen Augenmerk drauflegen.
Okay?
Okay, danke.
Gut.
So.